hello everyone thanks for joining us
today um i'm going to talk a little bit
about um some projects that i've been
working on in the lab my name is diana
rivera neda and i'm a research assistant
professor at the university of
pittsburgh in the
department of immunology and the tumor
microenvironment center
the title of my talk is fueling the
anti-tumor immunity using oncolytic
viruses encoding metabolic modulators
and just to set up the stage for my talk
i will briefly just want to touch on the
um the way that we are currently
managing
cancer
patients with immunotherapy as you know
in the last decade checkpoint blocking
therapy became the most promising
therapy out there
which basically harnesses the immune
system as a therapeutic tool
this
therapies have been very promising as
you can tell especially in certain
patient populations where you're seeing
about 20 to 40 percent of long-lasting
response
nonetheless in a lot of these tumor
types and other
cancers we are seeing an overall poor
therapeutic response some of them don't
respond at all from the beginning so
there's still uh quite a bit of space in
the field to better understand the
mechanisms underlying the lack of
response
to immunotherapy
but most importantly i think on this
this therapies cancer immunotherapy
highlights the incredible potential that
harnessing the patient's immune response
has
against the disease
and so um let's talk about what would be
the um the other barriers that uh
t cell infiltrating into the tumor need
to overcome beyond the stimulation of
inhibitory receptors which are the
targets for checkpoint bouquet
and one of the things that i think it's
critical to highlight is that the
the tumor microenvironment is very
heterogeneous among different patients
in which that the tumors can be
kind of roughly divided between these
hot cold and cold ignore tumors where
the t-cells have a different levels of
infiltration within the tumor and then
you'll find that some t-cells or in
general lymphocytes have barriers that
have to overcome to infiltrate such as
physical barriers chemokine signaling um
low to no tumor and neural antigens and
or
damage damage vascularization
and so there is also the recruitment of
suppressive immune cells as well as the
chronic stimulation in the tumor that
can cause diesel exhaustion and most
importantly the things that we're most
interested in in our lab is the
metabolic barriers that these
lymphocytes have to encounter
in the tumor microenvironment
and so focusing on the metabolic
barriers that you see in the tumor
the tumor microenvironment could be
considered a metabolic desert where t
cells have to compete with tumor cells
for nutrients in order to survive
consequently
t cells find themselves in a very
non-permissive microenvironment with
very low levels of nutrients low levels
of oxygen
in this case
described as hypoxia as well as the
accumulation of detrimental metabolites
such as high levels of lactate
which can
cause t-cells to become metabolically
repressed
and these metabolic repression has been
seen
from our lab in a couple of different
tumor types such as head and neck
cancers as well as melanomas where you
can see that the t-cells that infiltrate
the tumor in here describes a still
show a decrease in mito fm which would
be your mitochondria mitochondrial
content and this is decrease in both
head and neck and melanoma compared to
your
pbl
and so the things that we think about is
how to overcome these immunogenic
barriers and so firstly you want to turn
a cold tumor into a hot tumor so you
want to promote that t cell in
frustration or lymphocyte infiltration
into the tumor bed and then once you're
there you need to um
have to utilize metabolic modulators
that can improve the t cell function in
the tumor micro environment and the way
that we approach this is to basically be
able to combine these two approaches
and so one of the ways that we wanted to
um
address the problem about of a poor
lymphocyte infiltration was with the
utilization of oncolytic viruses and
just to give you a brief overview on how
they work um oncolytic viruses are
replication-competent viruses they come
in a few different flavors as you can
see in the graph
and the way that they work is by
basically two main
mechanisms they can selectively
replicate within the tumor and they call
what they call oncolysis
and this oncolysis can also produce an
induction of an anti-tumor immunity
and one of the um
major bonuses of these of these
therapeutics is that you they can also
serve as delivery for vectors for
therapeutic genes you can genetically
modify all these genes and include any
kind of
genetic
backpack basically that you can you want
to deliver into the tumor
um
we have already a one of the one of
these viruses approved by the fda it's
an hsv-1 engineer virus and it's treat
for the treatment of melanoma
and there are currently several clinical
trials ongoing for the combination of
checkbook oncolytic viruses
with checkpoints okay
and so um our lab is particularly using
a vaccinia backbone for our studies and
that's the oncolytics that i will be
talking about
so just to get started on the on our
project we wanted to set up a um
basically a melanoma in vivo model that
can gives us the uh
the makeup that we wanted to for this
tumor type basically we wanted a tumor
that was poorly infiltrated in terms of
cdat cells and also that was pd1
resistant and the way that we did this
was to generate a cell line from a ptmb
ref transgenic melanoma model we
had the mice that developed tumors we
isolated the tumors and developed a
single cell clone that we will call
clone 24 and as you can see here in the
in the bar graph in the cd8 the
percentage in the tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes is very much decreased
compared to your typical b16
infiltration um cd8
population and on the right you see the
tumor growth graph where you can see
that the tumors that were treated with
untyped pd-1 um have no response to the
treatment so we have a set up uh a
melanoma model set up we're
investigating are are therapeutic
and so here initially what you can see
is that when we treat uh melanoma tumors
this chlorine 24 with a well-type
vaccinia virus you are starting to see
some responses for the tumor you see a
partial respond of about
42
and
so uh we wanted to see what was actually
the makeup of the uh infiltration um of
these tumors after treatment
and as you can see here from single cell
analysis we can start seeing how are
these lymphocytes um distributed in the
tumor and one of the important things
that here to highlight is how in the pbs
group alone you have very little t cell
infiltration as you can see in the by
the pie charts about only like seven
percent there's quite a bit of
macrophages and monocytes um and then
particularly when you treat the tumors
with the vaccinia virus there's an
expansion of t-cell
the t-cell population there's also an
expansion of monocytes and a decrease in
the overall micro macrophage population
so this gives you an overview of how the
vaccinia virus affects the tumor the
tumor infiltrates
after treatment
and so looking a little bit more
specifically at the tumor infiltration
by flow cytometry
what we can find
by full cytometry as well is that
compared to the lymph node where you see
no
no changes in cda populations with the
vaccinia treatment which is also
very nice to see that there's no effect
into the lymph nodes you see that in the
till there's a dramatic increase of the
cda population after the vaccinia
treatment and
also important to highlight is that you
see a decrease of the phospho3-positive
t-rex population after the vaccemia
treatment and this is something that i
will touch on um towards the end of the
presentation
another important um
characteristic that we found in the cda
population of these tumors was that
there was a deficiency in their
metabolic state where you can see here
by twin btg where that shows glucose
uptake and myotracker for mitochondrial
content we see an overall decrease on
these two markers showing that there are
metabolic deficiencies in the t-cell
infiltration
and so
the idea now moving forward is how you
can you restore that metabolic function
of the t cells in the tumor
microenvironment you got the t-cells
into the tumor by using the oncolytic
now you need to overcome the different
barriers they encounter in the tumor and
so our lab has been able to do this in a
couple of different ways throughout the
years and as you can see here from this
uh text
we've done this by inducing pc and alpha
expression which promotes mitochondrial
biogenesis
we've done this by reducing oxygen
consumption from tumors uh through the
treatment of metformin allowing t cells
to use oxolof
um and we've done this also by using
41bp agonist where we know that it
promotes mitochondrial function and uh
consequently improving checkpoint okay
and so we were looking at other
metabolic
players that can also help us improve t
cell function and we decided to um
look a little bit into uh
pro-inflammatory cytokines and what we
found was that from the literature is
that leptin um
can also push t cells towards a more
oxidative
state where have been studies that shown
that they can stimulate fatty acid
oxidation as well as to as well as drive
a glucose to fatty acid um functions and
so this would give us an idea that
leptin could be uh
an interesting player and most
importantly that i'm not showing here we
do see that uh exhausted t cells can
express highly the leptin receptor
and so to do our initial studies
we did a
cda t cell culture in vitro where we
treat the t cells with different
concentrations of leptin and what we
find is that through metabolic analysis
of seahorse we show that leptin can
improve the oxygen consumption's rate as
you see in the top uh row of graphs
there's a higher okar which is oxygen
consumption rates and basal state as
well as higher spare respiratory
capacity and we can also see that there
is no major changes in terms of
glycolytic capacity
shown by the ecar
plot
and then when we look specifically at by
flow cytometry and mitochondrial content
in glucose uptake we do also see that by
leptin treatment you have an increase in
the mitochondrial mass staining
showing that leptin can actually have a
pro-oxidative
effect on t cells
and so how can we test the the effects
of leptin directly in the tumor
microenvironment the way that we uh came
about to do this experiments we decided
to take our melanoma model and uh
transduce them with a leptin gene where
we can see if the tumor will produce
leptin release it into the
microenvironment and this is exactly
what we find when the leptin is
expressed by a tumor they actually
release it into the tumor
microenvironment
and when you put these tumors into mice
um and follow their tumor growth we find
that the tumors that explode that are
expressing leptin are have a much
controlled tumor growth compared to
their control counterparts and also
increase the overall
survival of the mice
when we look at the tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes directly we do also see
similar to the
oncolytic treatments we see an increase
in the infiltration of cd8 as well as
the infiltration of cd4 t cells
most importantly we wanted to assess if
this effect of leptin uh in the on the
tumor growth was directly
directly correlated to the effects of
the cda t cells in the tumor so the way
that we did this was to
deplete the tumor the mouse from
cdas through it using an antibody and
what you find is that when you have a
tumor that is expressing leptin but you
depleted the cd8 from the tumor you no
longer have that control tumor growth
and these tumors start growing the same
as controls showing that is this effect
of tumor growth is dependent on cd8
function
more uh and further we were able to show
that this tumor
control growth was also dependent on the
expression of the leptin receptor
on
t cells where in this experiment we have
leptin receptor flux mice with a cd4
cree and we see that the tumors
the tumors that were expressed in leptin
that were
they were injected into the leptin
receptor knockouts also have a they lose
that a controlled tumor response showing
overall that the effects that we're
seeing in tumor growth are dependent on
the tumor infiltrating lymphocytes and
these lymphocytes being able to express
the leptin receptor
and so what is the functional state of
these tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
we find that these tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes when they are expressing
leptin they have a better functional
capacity as you can see here by
sustaining by looking at the expression
of interference gamma and tnf alpha
and as well that we we are observing an
improvement in mito and mitochondrial
function where we're seeing a higher
mitochondrial mass
in the tumors that are expressing leptin
and so
moving forward the idea is to be able to
deliver
the leptin directly into the tumor
microenvironment and the way that we did
this was by
cloning the leptin uh gene into a
vaccinia viral
expressing virus and we in that way what
we do is that we deliver the vaccinia to
the tumor the tumor will
the virus will release the leptin into
the tumor microenvironment and this will
improve the t cell function once they
get into the tumor
and when you we're looking at the
therapeutic responses of this vaccinia
virus what we see
is that the chlor24 melanoma model we
see a much better response with the
virus that expresses leptin as you can
see here there's a complete response
of about 27
in the melanoma model um we also
included a pancreatic cancer model
pancos2 where you don't see a complete
response but you definitely see a much
better partial response with the leptin
expressing virus um compared to the
virus control
when we're looking at the tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes we also see
that these tumors have a much better
functional t cell infiltration where you
can see that they're expressing much
more
uh cytokines in terms of tnf alpha and
in the pheno gamma compared to the
control virus
they're also producing they're also
generating
a lot more mitochondrial mass and this
is observed by the staining of vdac
you're seeing a lot more vdac a higher
percentage of vdac in the leptin
expressing virus tumors compared to
their controls and uh importantly too we
are actually observing an increase in uh
proliferative capacity in these t cells
as well where we see a higher percentage
of ti-67 staining
in the t cells from the
tumors
treated with the leptin vaccinia tumor
vaccinia virus
and so just to look a little bit further
at the populations that are in in the
tumor
after treatment and looking specifically
at the populations in terms of like the
t cell clusters we can divide the t
cells that are infiltrating into these
tumors after treatment in different
populations such as memory cytotoxic
c4t cells t-rex um exhausted and one of
the things that it was highlighted
during the analysis was that there was
an increase in general of the memory
population
and so when we did uh till analysis we
did see that the tumors that were
treated with the vaccine leptin have an
increase
in cd127 expressing tumor t cells
showing that in general there's a um and
a skewing towards a memory population
which would be also beneficial for
better uh response to the immunotherapy
so doing immediate so trying to see if
this memory activity is true
what we did was a memory experiment
where
we had a cohort of mice that got treated
with the vaccinia leptin expressing
virus
as we as i mentioned before there's a
complete response of about 30
so we took all of these complete
responders and we kept them alive for a
few days up to 20 days to make sure that
they don't
regress
once we knew that the tumor was
completely eradicated we took this
cohort
including a group of uh mystar uh
wild-type mice injected uh tumors again
to these mice and what we find is that
out of the 11 complete responders eight
never had tumor regression they never
grew another tumor again only three had
um
uh some tumor grow again and even then
it was a lot uh slower than the controls
that all develop tumors so this also
shows that by in improving the metabolic
capacity of the t cells in the tumor
micro environment you're also skewing
them toward towards a more memory like
population and probably potentially
having a better response to uh therapy
and so just to give a brief overview on
what i'm showing you now
we can say that our data suggests that
leptin can enable anti-tumor immune
responses in a tumor microenvironment
that is
metabolically deficient
and that oncolytic viruses expressing
methane can enhance the overall
therapeutic response to oncolytics
and that using these two
two strategies sorry of inducing t cell
and situation and at the same time
targeting the metabolic deficiencies
encountered into a micro environment
could be the most appropriate way to
go after a better therapeutic response
and so for future directions we're um
looking into determining the effects
that the oncolytic viruses direct the
colitic virus has directly on the till
population this is an ongoing project
right now in the lab
um and of course exploring the metabolic
regulators other metabolic regulators
that can be expressed in alkalinity
viruses in order to improve a
therapeutic response so we're constantly
thinking about other ways that we can
improve
on colitics and always looking for
targets metabolic targets
and just to give you a little bit of a
uh
brief uh data that we have that is uh
preliminary
um like i mentioned before i talked
about how foxb3 cd4
positive t cells
population decrease after
vaccinia treatment so that we found it
was very interesting that in a way we're
targeting the tear eggs which is good
and in the terms of like a tumor setting
and so in collaboration with um
with the hink lab here in pittsburgh who
develops
these pgf beta uh inhibitors he produced
a tga beta mini monomer which is
basically a com
a monomer that binds to the pj beta r2
receptor in
in this way it out competes a tga beta
and that way there's no um there's no tn
beta downstream signaling so what we
initially did was
treat cells with the vaccinia virus and
get
the supernatant from vaccinia control as
well as the vaccine
that had the tgf beta monomer and what
you see here in the graph when you just
have the control vaccinia plus cg of
beta you have a higher tissue beta
activity
when you include the supernatant from
the uh the cells that were treated with
the vaccinia tj beta virus you can see a
decrease in tgf-b activity in this
activity gets diluted as the supernatant
gets diluted as well showing that it's
specific for tj beta activity
and most importantly when we
look at the tumor growth with these with
this virus you actually do see an
improvement in treatment compared to the
vaccine control with the tgf beta
virus and so this is just the
preliminary data that we've been
developing in the lab and we're further
exploring um
in in with different um
compounds and so just to give a overall
summary for my talk
uh
vaccinia can be utilized to induce an
immune response in cold tumors pretty
efficiently um in this immune response
needs uh some metabolic support to be
able to function better
and
most importantly vaccinia viruses as
well as other oncolytics can ha can be
genetically modified to provide that
metabolic support
and so i just wanted to give a quick
acknowledgement for my lab um my lab
that i'm in with
my mentor greg delgov and everyone in
the lab and of course my collaborators
at pitt that have been instrumental for
this project to move forward and with
that um i'm done and if anybody has any
questions
in the future please contact me i'll be
happy to answer any questions you guys
have thank you